the death toll in Turkey continues to
climb a week after those devastating
earthquakes destroyed entire cities more
than 35 thousand people now are dead and
rescue efforts are still underway those
effects can be felt right here in Las
Vegas Brian will spoke to a man who was
lost at least nine members of his family
in the tragedy
it's been a tough week last week
first
three or four days straight I couldn't
sleep at all
both my wife and I all we did was
sitting and crying
because nothing helps gunas zetulu
better known by his friends and family
as G has never faced such loss so far
nine of his family members were killed
either during the Quakes or days after
while waiting to be found on the second
day they were still alive we know
because they were texting
like we are alive we are okay please let
come and rescue us gunas tried
everything he could to get Rescuers to
his family help never arrived in time a
volunteer rescue worker himself with Red
Rock search and rescue he understands
what these rescue workers are going
through his family is still waiting for
more answers we are trying to be hopeful
and happy and now trying to support my
family members who lost their
um you know other family members friends
their houses their workplaces
pretty much everything is destroyed
goonin says entire cities are wiped out
thousands of lives lost entire
livelihoods gone and even ancient
history destroyed
it's hard to even comprehend what all
happened disaster or catastrophe or
earthquake all these words are not
enough to describe the situation while
facing all the challenges and pain now
they are focused on helping those that
lived while honoring the lives that were
lost yeah hope no one in the world go
through this kind of things like in any
any person you know Brian will reporting
8 News Now